scarlett johansson sued the walt disney
company on thursday
claiming it breached her contract by
releasing her latest movie black widow
on disney plus
the same day premiered in theaters filed
in state court in los angeles
the lawsuit claims disney broke a
long-standing agreement with the actress
to release black widow as a wide
theatrical release
according to court filings sent to
forbes via johansen's lawyer
by offering the film to theater goers
and disney plus users at the same time
the suit claims disney lured the
picture's audience away from movie
theaters and towards its own
streaming service which harm johansson
because her pay for starring in black
widow
is based partly on bonuses for strong
box office sales
hollywood sources told forbes the
lawsuit could result in more than 50
million dollars in lost bonus payments
for johansen
disney's subsidiary marvel initially
planned to release black widow in may of
but the film's premiere was delayed due
to covet 19.
when the movie finally debuted in
theaters three weeks ago
disney plus subscribers could buy access
at home for 30 dollars
black widow earned 39 and a half million
dollars in u.s theaters on its opening
day
but box office sales dropped off steeply
the following week
at the time disney cited the company's
quote
focus on providing consumer choice and
serving the evolving preferences of
audiences
as the reason for the simultaneous
release johansen's attorney john
brolinski wrote in a statement thursday
afternoon
it's no secret that disney is releasing
films like black widow directly onto
disney plus to increase subscribers and
thereby boost the company's stock price
in a statement to several news outlets
disney called johansen's lawsuit
meritless
and quote especially sad and distressing
in its callous disregard for the
horrific and prolonged global effects of
the kovic 19 pandemic
disney claims the actress has already
earned 20 million dollars for her role
in black widow
and could receive more money due to the
film's disney plus release
[Music]
you